[موسيقى]
مساء الخير تسريبات البنتاجون هي الشغل
لكثير من دول العالم هذه الايام
تسريبات فعلا خطيره خطيره على كثير من
المستويات
التوابع اللي هتترتب عليها ايضا كبيره
وخطيره في مقبل الايام قبل ما نتكلم عن
اهم ما جاء في هذه التسريبات حتى هذه
اللحظه اذكركم بالقصه من البدايه والقصه
من البدايه تبدو بسيطه لكنها مربكه وغير
واضحه
قصه بتقول ان هذه التسريبات اللي هي عباره
عن وثائق وتقارير من الاجهزه الاستخبارات
الامريكيه المختلفه وهم 16 جهاز قدمت الى
البنتاجون ومن احد مقرات البنت كنت تسربت
الى
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تليجرام وتويتر
لكن كانت البدايه لا من تليجرام ولا من
تويتر ولكن من موقع تواصل اجتماعي صغير
نسبيا اسمه ديسكورد موقع تواصل اجتماعي
عدد متابعي حوالي 150 مليون مقر الاساسي
في سان فرانسيسكو واسس عام 2015
والاهتمام الاساسي لمستخدمي هو الجيمنج او
العاب الفيديو
بدات هذه الوثائق تتسرب تباعا بدايه من
يناير لم يشعر بها احد او لم يهتم بها
الكثيرون ربما ظنوا انها غير اصليه وانها
فيك ثم بدات تنتقل من ديسكورد الى
التليجرام
وتويتر وجذبت الانتباه الاهتمام الرسمي
بدا يظهر
والازمه او الفضيحه كلها بدات تاخذ شكلا
رسميا وتدخل وسائل الاعلام الكبيره عندما
قررت نيويورك تايمز نشر تحقيقا على هذه
التسريبات في سته ابريل الجاريه
قبل ما ادخل التسجيل في
ظهر يوم الخميس 13 ابريل 2023
واشنطن بوست نشرت منذ ساعات تحقيقا بتؤكد
فيه انها بدات تصل الى يعني بدايه الخيط
للكشف عن الشخص الذي يقف وراء هذه
التسريبات طبعا في البدايه الولايات
المتحده اشارت باصابع الاتهام الى الروس
اللي نفوا علمهم باي شيء عن هذه التسريبات
تسريبات بتسئ لهم على كل الاحوال انما
واشنطن بوست بتقول انها قدرت تتوصل الى
شخص كان يستخدمه غرفه الدردشه التي ظهرت
عليها هذه الوثائق لاول مره بدايه في
يناير وان هذا الشخص الذي تحدث اليهم دون
ان يكشف عن هويته بيقول ان احد معارفه
وهو شاب يصفه بالانعزال وانه شخص مهتم
كثيرا يعني بالسلاح والفاير
نشر هذه الوثائق التي حصل عليها من قاعده
عسكريه امريكيه بطريقه ما وانه قدر ياخذها
معاه البيت ويعمل منها صور سكرين شوتس
ونشر منها العشرات على غرفه دردشه في
البدايه بتضم حوالي 20 شخص حذفت هذه
الغرفه بعد ذلك من ديسكورد اللي بتقول ان
هي بتتعاون الان مع اجازه التحقيقات
الامريكيه
لمحاوله مساعدتهم عن الوصول الى المسرب
وانه الشخص اللي تحدث عن الى واشنطن بوست
بيقول ان هذا الصديق بيعرف باسم او جي اذا
كان اسم الحقيقيا او اسما وهميا وانه لن
يكشف عن اي تفاصيل عنه لجهات التحقيق هل
هذا ممكن هل هذا غير ممكن هل هذا دقيق
برومته الله اعلم لكن في كل الاحوال
التسريبات محل تحقيقات واسعه داخل
الولايات المتحده ومحل اهتمام كبير جدا في
كل دول العالم المختلفه التي نالتها هذه
التسريبات
البنتاجون
المسؤولين الامريكان اقروا اكثر من مره
بان هذه التسريبات اثنتك يعني فعلا هذه
الوثائق صحيحه لكنهم اشاروا الى ان بعضها
هاف بندكترد يعني تم تزييفه او التلاعب
فيه والمثال الواحد الوحيد الذي استخدمه
الامريكان للتدليل على ان بعض هذه الوثائق
تم تزييفه كان بيتعلق
بارقام الخسائر الروسيه في الحرب
الاوكرانيه وارقام الخسائر الاوكرانيه
ايضا في نفس الحرب الخلاصه ان احد الوثائق
اشارت الى ان عدد الخسائر في صفوف الروس
بتتراوح حتى الان بين 16 و 17 الف فيما
انه خسائر الاوكران بتتجاوز السبعين الف
والامريكان بيقولوا انه هذه الارقام تم
التلاعب بها من احد المتعاطفين مع الروس
او من الروس انفسهم ليظهروا ان اعدادهم
اقل بكثير اعداد خسائرهم اقل بكثير وخسائر
الاوكران اعلى بكثير فيما ان التقديرات
الامريكيه العكس اي الروايتين ادق الله
اعلم لكن الاهم ليس في هذه الوثيقه الاهم
في الصوره العامه الدقيقه اللي بترسمها
الوثائق لمجريات الحرب الدائره منذ 14
شهرا الوثائق بتتضمن معلومات تفصيليه
خطيره جدا عن الجيش الاوكراني تحديدا
ومعلومات كبيره ومهمه عن حجم اختراق
الامريكان للجيش الروسي اذا صحه هذه
الوثائق اهم ما جاء في هذه الوثائق نقدر
نقول بصفه عامه واحد ان الولايات المتحده
وحلف شمال الاطلسي منخرط بشكل مباشر في
هذه الحرب
منخرط بالتخطيط والمساعده ووجود قوات على
الارض داخل اوكرانيا كلنا تقريبا كل
العالم كان يعرف ذلك قبل ان تتسرب هذه
الوثائق لكن بعد ان تسربت هذه الوثائق فهي
تؤكد ما كان محل تخمين او ادعاءات كما
كانوا يقولون من الجانب الروسي الان لم
تعد ادعاءات ان صحت الوثائق
على سبيل المثال الولايات المتحده وفقا
للوثائق هي منخرطه في التخطيط والتدريب
وطبعا مساعده القوات الاوكرانيه
بالمعلومات
والمعدات والتحديث الاستخباراتي اللحظي
على سبيل المثال احد الوثائق بتقول انه
الولايات المتحده هي من اقترحت على
الاوكران ان يقوموا بهجومهم المضاد في
منتصف مايو المقبل ليه بيقولوا ان
تقديراتهم ان هيكون الامطار قد جفت والارض
قد اصبحت صلبه بما يكفي لعمور كل المدرعات
والمركبات الاوكرانيه باتجاه الروس في
الاماكن التي احتلوها من اوكرانيا منذ بدء
الحرب
هم اللي بيقولوا ايضا انه الوثائق بتقول
انه في 12 لواء
اوكراني هم الاكثر جاهزيه لخوض هجوم
الربيع او الاكونتر اتاك المنتظره منذ
شهور من الجانب الاوكراني لتحرير الاراضي
التي احتلها الروس منذ بدايه الحرب منهم
تسع الويه تم تجهيزهم بالكامل وتدريبهم
بالكامل من حلف شمال الاطلسي ومن قوات
امريكيه الوثائق بتضيف ان هذا التدريب لم
يتم فقط خارج اوكرانيا كما هو معلن ان
ضباط اوكران بيروحوا الى بريطانيا وامريكا
وبولندا ويتم تدريبهم هناك قوات من حلف
شمال الاطلسي موجوده على الارض ويشاركون
في اداره المعارك ووفقا للوثائق فان هناك
71 عسكري امريكي على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وفي كتيبه بتضم 97 من جنود العمليات
الخاصه التابعين لحلف شمال الاطلسي وفي
وثيقه مؤرخه ب 23 مارس 2023
بتحدد ارقامهم وبتقول انه العدد الاكبر من
بريطانيا 50 عسكريا 17 عسكريا فرنسا 15
الولايات المتحده 14 الى اخره
طبعا في دول انكرت هذا الكلام فرنسا على
سبيل المثال كانت اول دوله تنكر وجود اي
قوات لها على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لكن هذا ما تذهب اليه الوثائق
الوثائق ايضا بترسم صوره بقى يعني هذا هذا
جانب من الوثائق
بيؤكد انه حلف شمال الاطلسي والولايات
المتحده منخرطين بشكل كامل في الحرب على
روسيا على الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكن في
وثائق بترسم صوره
على امكانيات الجيش الاوكراني الصوره ديت
صوره يعني محبطه جدا للاوكرانيا بتظهر انه
اوكرانيا الجيش اجهد جدا ينقصوا الكثير من
المعدات يصعب ان يستمر في حربه ضد الروس
لفتره طويله بيشككوا في جدوى اي مكاسب
يمكن ان يحققها الاوكران في الهجوم الربيع
او الهجوم المضاد المنتظر منذ شهور
وبيتكلموا عن تفاصيل التفاصيل ديت يعني
تذهلك
الامريكان على اطلاع بكل الاسلحه او
الذخائر الموجوده لكل منظومه التسليح داخل
اوكرانيا عارفين اللي في المخازن عارفين
متوسط عمليات الاطلاق وبالتالي بيقدروا
امتى يمكن ان تتوقف هذه المنظومات عن
استخدام نتيجه اما تدميرها او نفاد
الذخائر وبيدوا على سبيل المثال لان
الكلام كبير جدا تفاصيل عن منظومات الدفاع
الجوي s300 وهو برضو منظومه دفاع روسيه او
اي اس 10 اي اس 11 منذ ما الدفاع ايضا
روسيه بتستخدمها اوكرانيا وازاي ان
الذخائر
والتي سوف كانت ان تنفذ لهذه المنظومات
اللي بتستخدم بشكل كثيف لصد الهجمات
الروسيه فضلا عن ان هي دمرت ايضا او دمرت
كثير منها وبالتالي بنهايه مايو او في 20
مايو وفقا للتقديرات الامريكان في هذه
الوثائق لن تكون هذه المنظومات الدفاع
الجوي قادره على
الدفاعات الجويه وبالتالي الجيش الاوكراني
سوف يكون صيدا سهلا للقوات الروسيه هل هذا
التناقض ناتج عن انه هذه وثائق مبعثره او
غير كامله هل ناتج عن ان هناك وثائق اخرى
بترى انه هجوم الربيع يجب ان
يسبقه امداد القوات الامريكيه وحلف شمال
الاطلسي الجيش الاوكراني بما يحتاجه
لاتمام الهجوم ام لان الوثائق غير دقيقه
الله اعلم الوثائق ايضا بترسم صوره سيئه
جدا للجيش الروسي وبتعتبره الصوره العامه
انه جيش مرهق ومخترق مرهق واضح لكن كمان
بتتكلم على انه مخترق بمعنى ان المخابرات
الامريكيه بتحصل على معلومات دقيقه جدا
اما لان لديهم يعني عملاء
تمم يعني زرعوهم في الوحدات المؤثره داخل
الجيش الروسي او وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اجهزه الامن الروسيه وربما داخل كمان
مجموعه
الروسيه اللي هي بتلعب دور مهم جدا في
معارك ضخمه او ان هي عندها قدرات
استخباريه متفوقه متمكنها من التالي بتعرف
خطط الجيش الروسي بتقدر ترسل صوره
في اللحظه
حاليا وهو الصاروخ بيتحرك وهو بيتم تجهيزه
للاطلاق والقوات بتتحرك لحظه بلحظه مش دي
ليه مش بعدها بسنتين ولا تلاته لحظه بلحظه
وبتعرف ايضا الاهداف اللي الجيش الروسي
لان هي عارفه مخططاته الاهداف التي يرغب
الجيش الروسي في استهدافها وتغذي بها
الاوكران على الفور وده بيشرح لنا لماذا
تعثر الهجوم الروسي
يعني احتاج الروس 14 شهرا دون ان يحققوا
جزءا كبيرا من اهدافهم مره اخرى اذا صحت
هذه الوثائق ويبدو ويبدو ان الكثير منها
صحيح بشهاده الامريكان وبشهاده الروس
الروس بيقولوا ايه على الارجح 90% منها
سليم وعشره في الميه منها قد تم تزييفه
لخداعنا اي عشره بقى يعني طبعا مساله
متروكه للتاويلات الوثائق ايضا بتتناول
مجموعه من الدول الحليفه للولايات المتحده
هو غير الحليفه للولايات المتحده وبتكشف
كثيرا من الاسرار التي لم يكن يعلم بها
احد يعني على سبيل المثال الوثائق بتؤكد
تجسس الولايات المتحده على اسرائيل وانه
تقديرتهم كالاتيل ما توفر من وثائق انه
اسرائيل وفقا لاحد الوثائق يمكن
اقناعها بالمشاركه في الحرب على الروس
بامداد الاوكران باسلحه والوثيقه بتقول
انه ممكن الضغط عليهم او اقنعهم الامداد
الاوكران باسلحه مؤثره ومهمه في ساحه
المعارك نفس الوثيقه بتقول ان الروس على
ان الاسرائيليين على الارجح سوف
يقومون بهذه الخطوه في حالتين الحاله
الاولانيه انه الاوكران ان الروس يمد
ايران باسلحه متقدمه مثلا 35 او منظومه
دفاع اس 400 او اذا قام الروس
باعاقه الحركه الاسرائيليه الحره على
الاجواء السوريه بان هم ينشروا مثلا
منظومات دفاع جوي روسي متطوره في سوريا
الامر الذي سوف يكلف الاسرائيليين الكثير
اثناء عملياتهم المنتظمه لضرب اهداف
ايرانيه وسوريه داخل
سوريا
ايضا الوثائق بتقول لنا ان هم بيتجسسوا
على الموساد واحد الوثائق بتقول انه
الموساد شجع على سبيل المثال العاملين
لديه على التظاهر او المشاركه في
المظاهرات ضد بنيامين نتنياهو مؤخرا في
ازمه ما يعرف بالاصلاح القضائي الوثائق
بتقول ان هي تجسست على مصر واحد الوثائق
بتقول ان هي
قدرت ترصد تعليمات من الرئيس السيسي الى
شخص على الارجح هو وزير الانتاج الحربي
والرئيس السيسي بيقول له يجب ان نصنع
ونصدر 40 الف صاروخ 40,000 رقم مهول جدا
يعني يصعب تصديقه لكن اربعين الف صاروخ ما
بتقول لناش انواع الصواريخ وان هذا
التصنيع يجب ان يتم تصنيعه وارساله سرا
الى الروس والمحادثه اجمالا بتقول ان هذا
مكافاه للروس على مساعداتهم هذا اقل ما
يمكن ان نفعله للروس الذين ساعدونا كثيرا
الوثيقه ما بتقولش انواع الصواريخ ولا
لماذا تحتاجها بشكل ملح روسيا ولا ما نوع
المساعدات
طبعا التي قدمها الروس للمصريين وهم
ممتنون لها
المصريون نفو هذه الروايه جمله وتفصيلا
لوشن بوست وشنو حمله على وشم بوست
الامريكان قالوا لا نعلم حتى هذه اللحظه
على المستوى الرسمي ان هذه
الصفقه قد تمت يعني ما نعرفش حاجه عن مدى
دقه هذا الكلام هل كانت مجرد نيه ولم تتم
ام ان الوثيقه باجمالها مزوره الوثائق
ايضا بتتناول
تعاون محتمل بين الامارات العربيه
والمخابرات الروسيه اذ ان احد الوثائق
بتقول انه المخابرات الامريكيه سجلت
لمجموعه من ضباط المخابرات الروس وهم
يتفاخرون باقناع الامارات بالتعاون معهم
ضد تحركات المخابرات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه في المنطقه الوثائق ايضا
بتتجسس على حريفتهم كوريا الجنوبيه ورصدت
اجتماع لمسؤولين في جهاز الامن القومي
الكوري الجنوبي
وفي هذا الاجتماع
المستشارين
يعني منقسمين على انفسهم هل نستجيب للضغوط
الامريكيه ونعطي اوكرانيا سلاحا
وام يعني نتمسك بموقفنا المحادي تفاديا
لتدهور العلاقه مع الروس ووفقا للوثيقه
احد المستشارين قال يمكن ان نجد حلا وسطا
بان احنا نبيع اسلحه لبولندا وبولندا تقوم
من وراء ظهورنا باعطائها للاوكران
وبالتالي نتملص من المسؤوليه الحقيقه في
تفاصيل كثيره في الوثائق تستحق ان نقراها
نقراها ونحاول فهمها لكن لا نصدقها
بالضروره فقط للمعرفه الايام والشهور
المقبله سوف تبين لنا ما كان صادقا منها
وما كان كاذبا لكن المؤكد مجموعه من
الامور سواء صحت كلها كذبت كلها او صدقه
بعضها وكذب بعضها الاول ان الولايات
المتحده مخترقه كثير من الدول الحلفاء قبل
الاعداء هل هذا جديد ابدا مش جديد هذا
يعني قديم جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا وايضا
الولايات المتحده مخترقه من كثير من هذه
الدول وهذه الدول تعلم كثير عن تحركات
الولايات المتحده ربما اكثر مما يتخيل
الامريكان لكن الجديد ان في وثائق بتقول
لنا تفاصيل هذا الاختراق المهول بالمناسبه
في 2020
كان في قصه تستحق ان احنا نتوقف عندها
لاحقا يعني انه
الوشم بوست عمل التحقيق خطير جدا سميته ده
انتلج
انقلاب الاستخباراتي للقرن 21 اشارت فيه
الى انه شركه كريبتو اي جي السويسريه اسم
الشركه كده اللي
تاسست في الخمسينات وبتعمل منذ الخمسينات
الى وقت قريب جدا في مجال حساس وهو مجال
تصنيع ماكينات التشفير اللي هو الماكينات
اللي بيعملوا عليها التشفير تستخدمها
الجيوش واجهزه الامن القومي واجهزه
المخابرات بحيث يستحيل او يصعب جدا على اي
دوله اخرى ان تتعرف على شفرات ورسائل هذه
الدول اكتشفوا ان هذه الشركه اللي هي
الاشهر في مجالها واللي بتتعاون مع معظم
دول العالم اكتشفوا انه
هذه الشركه مملوكه للمخابرات الامريكيه من
سنه 70 لسنه 2018
ومنذ 1970 لغايه 1993 كانت تشاركها
الملكيه جهاز المخابرات الالماني ثم
انفردت الولايات المتحده بملكيتها من 93
حتى 2018 يعني الشركه اللي بتؤمن هذه
الدول من ان يتم اختراقها ثلاث مملوكه
للسي اي ايه ولفتره بين
المخابرات الالمانيه اللي كانوا بيستخدموا
ملكيتهم للشركه للاطلاع على اسرار 148
دوله حول العالم مجموعه اخرى من الملاحظات
انه هذه الوثائق بتؤكد لنا ان الحرب فعلا
رسميا ليست بين اوكرانيا وبين الروس
ولكنها بين الغرب كله وبين الروس ليس
جديدا لكن فكره ان الوثائق تقولنا ان في
جنود امريكانا ومن دول حلف شمال الاطلسي
هذا يمكن ان الروس ان هذا حرب مفتوحه بين
الروس وبين حلف شمال الاطلسي ويمكن
ان يؤدي قتل هذه القوات الى تصعيد اخطر
مما
يتخيل الطرفان الملحوظه الاخيره
والملاحظات كثيره انه الدول دي رغمنا دول
ديمقراطيه لكنها ضللت شعوبها التضليل مثلا
بالنسبه للامريكان بالنسبه للامريكان
والبريطانيين وغيرهم على مصرين المسار
الاول ان مفيش دوله لا امريكا ولا فرنسا
ولا بريطانيا استاذنت من برلماناتها في ان
ترسل جنودا جنودا الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه
هذا يحتاج اذنا هذا لم يحدث
وبالتالي في خرق يجب ان تحاسب عليه هذه
الدول وفقا للاعراف القانونيه
والمنطق الديمقراطي
الامر الثاني انه التضليل تم على اساس ان
الراي العام الامريكي والغربي بيؤيد
استمرار هذه الحرب على اساس انه الروس
كادوا ان ينهاروا وانه الاوكران بيقوموا
بجهد استثنائي في الدفاع عن اراضيهم وان
فرص الانتصار كبيره جدا للاوكران فوسائل
في استطلاعات الراي بتقول لا مانع ان
تواصلوا الحرب بما ان الهدف ميسور ومقبول
ويمكن ان يتحقق الوثائق دي بتقول لنا ان
الهدف ليس ميسورا ويصعب ان يتحقق وانه
السلطات الامريكيه والسلطات الاوروبيه
المختلفه خدعت شعوبها وصورت الاوكران على
انهم اقوى بكثير مما هم في حقيقه الامر
عليه وبالتالي قدموا املا واهيا على امل
ان يحافظوا على يعني
تاييدا شعبيا
للتدخل الغربي وحقيقه الامر ان المساله
ليست بهذا الشكل وان الحرب اه صحيح انه
المساعدات الغربيه ارهقت الروس لكنها لا
تعني ابدا ان فرص انتصار اوكرانيا قريبه
او ممكنه على الاقل في المستقبل المنظور
اشكركم ومع تطورات هذه الوثائق يقول لنا
متابعات اخرى مره اخرى لا نجزم ابدا ابدا
بصحه اي شيء في هذه الوثائق فقط نعرض ما
جاء فيها لننتظر ونرى اشكركم والى لقاء